on perd l adorable le faire j'espère que
l'une est ancien la fête sur ton
assassinat ce matin les obsèques du
journaliste diego charles ont été
célébrées dans la ville de jérémie à
l'ouest de l'île le journaliste de
vision 2000 a été abattu dans la nuit du
29 au 30 juin dans une rue de
port-au-prince également tué dans la
fusillade l'activiste politique netty
duclair c'est elle qui était
probablement cibler un meurtre politique
a ajouté aux comptes sinistre des bandes
criminelles armées la capitale donc
c'est la désolation au milieu de la
presse pas mal des analyses ont été
tuées jusqu'à maintenant pas de vérité
sur la mort de ses deux saisons
ces meurtres ont été suivis par une
quinzaine d'autres cette nuit là le 25
juin à la guerre de gangs fait 40 morts
à cité-soleil marié yolaine dit qu'il
est impossible de compter les victimes
d'assassinats qui n'ont cessé
d'augmenter ces trois dernières années
du pouvoir parce qu'ils les autorités il
sème là quand ils veulent ils allaient
droit de vie et de mots je vous dirais
que et seulement si le pays n'est pas
dit le chef de gang le plus connu est
l'ancien policier jimmy chérigié un lien
ce par me ku chef du g9 une des plus
grandes bandes armées qui n'a pas hésité
à appeler à la vengeance de la mort du
président je venais le mot east hope in
moun ki ena opposition cio qui fait
complot à bourgeois ceux ci pourront
livrer président son complot nationale a
été national opera isséens n'a pesé tout
basse mobilisez vous c'est devenu un
acte politique
on va regarder ses vidéos il a un
discours sur ce qui doit se passer un
discours violent mais certes mais
m'indispose en main et on se dit
et comme on se demande comment ils
m'appellent
les prochaines semaines sous je venais
le moïse les gangs ont pris de
l'importance et sont lourdement armés
on en a recensé 162 avec 3000 membres
plus la moitié à port-au-prince
difficile nle anime aussi une émission
culturelle à la radio elle a voulu
comprendre le phénomène des gangs et de
la misère qui en est la source et le
raconte dans un livre les villages de
dieu c'est le nom d'un des bidonvilles
de la capitale
dans ces cités précaire où les maisons
sont faites de taux de cartons de
plastique ya des gens qui vivent ya des
gens qui espèrent il ya des gens qui
rêvent et aujourd'hui
apparu d'eau et que de 2
chef de gang ou de quitter le pays
il s'agissait de montrer ce désespoir
quand même temps il
des membres de gangs
il ya beaucoup de criminels n'est pas
optimiste pour la suite
nous savons tous que ça nettoie par
mieux
parce que personne n'a décidé que ça
devrait aller mieux jean michel leprince
sera du canada port au prince